[Music]  nice to be  [Music]  that was brilliant let's give it another  go  [Music]  are you seeing this  [Music]  a bit more covert  [Music]  yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a  job with peace  do we know each other  time  reality reality  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question isn't it  every universe  is different  each one  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you  the name's captain carter  i am the  watcher i observe all that transpires  here  but i do not  cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  a ravager never flies solo  i said never flies solo  is that some kind of catchphrase  you heard me wear it for a second  journey to face the unknown  and ponder the question  what if  [Music]  you